Alo đợ tí Đợi tôi một
Ok Xin chào bạn ờ ừ à Đây để mình copy
quay lại code cái dự án web bán
hàng đợi tôi một tí tôi phải tắt bớt
code của công ty đã Ờ tôi sẽ mở thư mục
mới
cham
anh Bình anh ấy kiểu bảo kiểu zoom thế
sợ zoom có zoom lắm đâu nhỉ cỡ chữ thế
này được mà nhỉ zoom lắm đâu Đúng không
mấy ông thấy to quá không Tôi thấy bình
thường mà đúng không chữ mỗi chỗ này chữ
to này tôi sẽ tôi sẽ kiểu chỉnh lại cái
phông chữ ở đây cho nó bé tí
conso cho là 20
thôi đúng không À không terminal Chứ
đó chữa này to lắm không nhỉ Thấy bình
thường mà đúng
không Ok
Thì
Ừ tôi nhớ là anh vừa xem anh Mạnh Tuấn
chia sẻ thì nó có tiện ích gì nhỉ tiện
ích
ích cho cái mấy cái biểu tượng của
file team thì
thế
nào
cơ Xem
nà
example git
git để tôi thử
Ok ờ không không phải view
mấy ông sẽ thấy là tôi đang cài những
tiện í này
này arel in cái gì gì đó pp int Intel l
gì đó
Ờ recom mấy cái
có Blade chư nhở Hình như tôi tôi chẽ
cài
Blade Đợi tí BL snip này BL formatter
[âm nhạc]
Ồ Hồi trước tôi nhớ tôi cài cái vụ này
mỗi dùng cách sau Blade thế này cũng
được
nhỉ Kiểu dùng cái cái thẻ này tự thêm
cách
cái r pl cái này cái gì
Ồ hay phết Chắc chắng bao giờ làm thế
đâu Đôi khi cà nhiều quá m kiểu không
không v động đến ý
xem tôi sinh năm bao nhiêu á
Ừ tôi sinh năm
97 có thể là 96 phiên bản lỗi cũng được
vì tôi sinh tháng 1 của năm
nói chung hôm nay giới thiệu lại với các
bạn thì hôm nay mình sẽ quay trở lại
ngồi code cái trang web bán hàng cái
trang web mà Hồi trước mình đang code
giờ còn mấy cái dự án khác thì tôi không
hứa được là
Tôi không hứa được là sẽ bao giờ thì
mới nó yêu cầu cái git gì gì đó Ok kệ
không hứa được là bao giờ mới có quay
quay lại
kiểu ngồi codt mấy cái đấy vì tính ạ
không có thời gian mấy nữa và cũng gọi
như nào thấy là cũng không không chắc là
không mặn mà về nó lắm nữa không rõ được
Nhưng mà tôi thấy tôi có rất nhiều ý
tưởng tôi sẽ phải u ưu tiên thời gian
thì có hạn con người nguồn lực cũng có
hạn nên mình sẽ phải Ưu tiên những cái
cần hơn đúng không ạ đ sao có vai á vai
đâuu nhỉ Thôi cả vai á đâu view
quá
Buồn Hình như à đâu Hình như là có con
ship d
Ờ Bây giờ mình cần phải quay trở lại xem
là hồi trượng gần đây nhất mình đã code
cái gì đã 3 tháng trước
á hình hình như là code cũ tôi không đẩy
lên thì phải Tại sao tận 3 tháng trước
nhỉ
Ừ th say s sai hôm trước là tôi nhớ tôi
làm cái
vụ Thôi xong hình như là hồi trước là
mình làm cái
vụ check out rồi mà nhỉ Tôi nhớ là có
động đến bên check out rồi hay là hôm
đấy lười không đẩy lên
nhỉ check
out controller xem lại
đấy Cái này cảnh báo ạ
code hay vì dùng
kiểu à Dùng p st cảnh báo K khùng à quên
chưa composer install và sao
composer bị
viết router tố ưu được không Ví dụ có
một router
là ser truyền nhiều th số khiến đ lúc em
bị
lặn em khai báo ID K Anh thấy không ổn
rồi thức ra nó phải category ID xong rồi
tr idong rồi ID Nhưng mà thực tế
thì cái n này là em đang muốn sửa cho
Cái gì
đã Bởi vì nếu mà sửa cho product Theo
như anh đang nhìn thì nó sửa product thì
rõ ràng là em chỉ cần truyền mỗi cái
product ID xong rồi à Nghĩa là trong
router ấy trong router thì em sẽ gọi đến
product ID thôi Sau đó thì em em cái cái
hàm đấy của em sẽ sửa cái gì Cái method
đấy em sẽ sửa gì Ví dụ là cập nhật
category thì sẽ là update category sẽ
viết router kiểu dạng là Anh thử ví dụ
product đúng không ID đúng không xong
rồi update category chẳng h
category kiểu như này Đấy xong rồi trên
trong này sẽ truyền thêm category ID đấy
Còn nếu mà em truyền thêm cả tha thì nó
sẽ ở đây cũng được sao cả đấy Kiểu kiểu
như
này method này sẽ method p hiểu là nó sẽ
cầm nhật thường nó sẽ liên quan cầm nhật
thế là được không Sao p stone của anh
đâu á đây
à anh Thực ra là có tôi có cài cái này
vào máy đấy chứ tôi còn không pin lại
cái v code cơ đây để tôi pin lại PS code
đy tôi có cài cái này pp st tôi vẫn còn
hạn Ờ thậm chí là Ừ tôi bây giờ tôi quay
lại đi dậy rồi Chính xác là tôi còn có
gọi như này Ờ bây giờ sẽ sẽ có thể xin
được Mayu ở lại gia hạn nữa đấy nhưng mà
tôi vẫn muốn thử góp nhìn khác muốn thử
trải nghiệm khác bao gồm việc là đấy
mình mình thử code bằng một cái IDE khác
thậm chí là tôi không dùng chận Tôi có
cái Email meu thì đương nhiên là sẽ có
thể kích hoạt được copilot nhưng mà tôi
bây giờ tôi thử dùng cái EX là là code
ium này code này cái này miễn phí đươ
nhiên là có thể thêm bản trản phí nhưng
mà tôi không nhớ bản trản phí nó có thêm
cái gì Hiện tại thì tôi thấy cái này
cũng tương đối Nó Tôi nghĩ là nó cũng
phải được tầm 70 80 70 % với copilot tôi
thấy là theo góc nhìn của tôi thôi là
copilot vẫn hơn nhưng mà tôi muốn thử
mọi cái khác đấy Nên là nói chung là nó
sẽ kiểu dạng mà mình mình nên thêm nhiều
góp nhìn đấy Giống như là ở công ty thì
tôi dùng vẫn dùng ma này vẫn dùng pp
stor này Nói chung là vẫn code theo kiểu
khác đấy thì còn ở nhà thì dùng máy win
xong rồi cài vest code cài thêm những
cái khác thì mình sẽ có thêm nhiều các
nhìn vào cái code của mình hơn đúng
không ạ Ừ đương nhiên là tôi cảm thấy
hiện tại hiện tại tôi vẫn đang cố làm
quen và tôi thấy là đúng à Ui một IDE có
khác phải trả phí nó có khác đúng không
cái này thì tôi vẫn nhìn theo góc độ là
nó giống Editor hơn tức là tức là kiểu
mình nhìn mọi thứ dễ và dễ thao tác các
thứ các thứ chứ chứ nó không tiện không
thể dùng từ tiện và vs code được theo
tôi là như
nhiều người thích kiểu nhỏ gọn tinh
chỉnh xong rồi mình thích Chỉnh gì thì
chỉnh đấy
bởi vì một phần là ở sinh viên ở trường
thì cái này lỗi không tìm được cái này
này
cơa
này ơ à hình như là
anh ơ Hình như là
anh Anh Bình Anh chỉnh lại cái cái
command của tôi rồi V Mọi khi tôi dùng
phím
An sử dụng được phím Ctrl rồi này cũng
tiện này làm gì có không có file này à
file admin rồi tạm xóa này đi
Vậy ok như không
nay nghe được cả tiếng quạt chạy
à Còn không
Ờ tôi để cho quạt tàn nhiệt chạy mà Đúng
là dùng máy win có khác quay lại máy win
phải chơi qua tản nhiệt cho dù dùng máy
m Macbook e thì không không quan trọng
điều đấy
Hiện tại thì công ty tôi là đang đang
xem cả hai nghĩa là hồi trước là làm
view 2 Xong rồi bây giờ Dữ án mới thì
dùng view 3 nhưng mà đương nhiên là vẫn
có vài chỗ thì vẫn dùng view 2 nghĩa là
dự án của tôi là có mà ông Hình dung là
có tận à 1 2 3 3 ba giao diện cho ba ba
tệp khách hàng khác nhau một cái là là
admin một cái seller một cái customer
nên cái customer luôn là mới nhất cần
tốt nhất nên là sẽ áp dụng luôn hàng
view 3 cần luôn phải nâng cấp còn còn
admin seller thì bản chất là dùng lại
cái giao diện cũ cũng được Nói chung là
nó về về cơ bản về bên giao diện quản lý
thực ra chỉ cần thao tác dễ chứ không
cần quan tâm vể giao diện đẹp hay hay là
kiểu ngầu các thứ các thứ mình chỉ cần
đủ tính năng để là được
đấy
hỗ trợ JavaScript kiểu như bị phân
biệt Ừ cái này thì anh chưa rõ
hồi trước nhá Không biết các bạn nhớ
Trang này không
B charm
chte Yeah không chạy được
À đúng rồi chưa Mở
Dragon cho bạn nào không nhớ thì mình đã
từng có cái
lagon
này dat bas
nữa sẽ tạo một cái mới tên là
panchang
p
bùm rồi
ạ sau đó thì disc Connect đi mình sẽ có
một thằng mới là
An cham này lưu lại này Ok mở lên này đó
Bây giờ
lệnh là pp này
atisan
se chẳng nhớ là mình có có SH hay không
cơi Ồ đang in production luôn á định
vậy
xin các thứ thứ này Ok
này không quan tâm với
này mail Chắc phải sao hửi redit thì ra
có rồi
description
tạo bảo như không có prescription Ok
chạy
thôi bảng đc Tại sao cổ mô
tả th sai sai nhỉ
ờ đợi tôi tí Đợi
à
thành content
á Ai là người
Ờ ok đổi cũng
được nhưng mà gọi nhở mà không sửa shit
n là nó chạy bị
fail đer À đây cho được đến
này này
factory
db2
shit Ok lỗi sang cái khác rồi Ờ category
tha t thle
tí
category
Factory f unic unic rồi nhưng vẫn
trùng mình sẽ thêm cái TH ở đằng trên
đầu cho chắc chắn không trùng đi
đấy admin out category
product đâ tả lại trang xem
được
ok chộng tương đối nhở đúng không
thôi à mình ch ch
key
này
chy ref ta
đ Các bạn nhớ giao diện này không
ạ
đi ch là admin
cho Hình như chưa Tạo phím tắt cho cái
router
clear
C
Ok
nhỉ Nó phải ưu tiên hàng ngày chứ đúng
không ha Chính vì đặt nó lúc đầu như này
thành ra em kia phải đặt nó dài ngoằng
như
thế Tôi lần đầu tôi mới thấy kiểu vụ này
đấy kiểu đặt tên đặt tên thư mục Em đang
học khóa SQL của anh mà sử dụng mysql là
chú quá Ừ đúng rồi Nếu mà em mà dùng My
SQL mà học khóa đấy thì nó sẽ có nhiều
cái nó khác tí nhưng mà gọi nhờ nó không
hẳn khác nhau nhiều trừ khi em học sang
m cái bên chuyên sâu chuyến sâu nó sẽ
khác hơn một tí thì Nếu có thể em cài
SQL Server để cho thao tác cho hiểu rõ
bản chất cũng được mình phải thực hành
mình mới hiểu sau đó Thực tế là thực tế
là thằng MQ cũng có cái đấy nhưng gọi
như nào nhỉ nói chung là làm để cho gọi
là mình biết thôi và mình cảm thấy thích
hơn về sq thôi chứ để mà nói thì đi làm
anh thấy ít ít khi mà động vào hết tất
cả các mng đấy lắm Ok có một câu để hỏi
chat cpt rồi ạ đó
là đó là kiểu tô này đợ tí đợ
t tôi có router lare à Tôi router admin
và thư mục admin trong
public Tôi muốn khi gõ thnh địa chỉ
ando là admin thì nó vào r chứ không
phải thư mục
kia thì làm thế nào à thôi chẳng cần n
thì làm thế
m12 20 không anh em tôi có nang dùng
Macbook
e kiểu 2020 đấy Ờ g thành chỉ vroid đều
hướng bạn đến
mà
Ờ tôi sẽ mở provider này router provider
Tại sao còn có cái này nhỉ dasb để mà
upload inage
trước chịu đãy xem nào
Ờ tu xóa cái này đi nó chỉ admin thôi
này tiếp theo là ghi đ thêm đúng không ạ
sẽ có file HT
accet đây đ đề
vẫn bị để xem
nào
Ừ để chắc thì tôi sẽ chạy cái optimize
này nó clear config và cả router
chạy nào chúc mừng vẫn
nào rewi on r mà nhở nhờ rewi on là được
rồi
đấy Thử
mặc định cho hoạt động mong đợi thứ tự
có thể ảnh hưởng nên làm bảo rồi ghi đề
được đặt trước các luật khác
để Ok trước mật khác
luôn
đấy
hả nó vừa báo một cái gì có cảnh báo ở
đấy Cái này tôi mới ghi thêm mà đúng
nhỉ màu này nó đang báo sai mà đúng
á Ừ con này Thực ra vẫn chơi cũng có
chơi game được này nhưng mà tôi không
chưa chơi mấy cái tự game nặng nặng
c
cách kiểm
[âm nhạc]
đâu
lại
này chạy vẫn được này admin
đ lạ nhỉ hay do qu này à đâu biết được
prefix các thứ đàng hoàng này chứ đúng
không Bây giờ tôi Giả sử Giả sử
tôi đổi tên cái này đi một như này chẳng
ạ Giả sử
thế đó chứng tỏ là nó vẫn ưu tiên theo
thằng
kiểu kia cũng được Tôi thấy cách kiểu
kia nó dễ hơn đấy
kia admin
1 còn hơn là để cho người dùng phải nhập
cái link nó rõ dài như thế
Ờ f
này admin này layout này chắc là cũng dễ
thôi cập nhật tí là được
mà mở file Blade lên đầu tiên là phải
cảm ơn luôn ạ
Đâu pl có gì hay nào vẫn formatter
đâu Chưa biết được là nó sẽ làm cái gì
đây được dùng những đâu nào Ok 1 1
ô dùng ở nhớ chỗ phết dùng dùng cở trong
asset
luôn trong Ok inmate các thứ các thứ ù
thế tôi không đổi được rồi khó
một ý hay cũng là một ý hay
để để thử nhá Ừ tôi xóa xử rồi ông mới
bắt đầu bình
luận rồi x ok ghi đè lên đúng không Ok
pp
Đúng rồi
nào thư mục này cũng không nhận cái
admin này không nhận hay là do chưa lê
kch nhỉ tậ
code bằng p
rồi Không nhận mấy không ạ Thôi tôi
nghĩa là để tránh mất công tôi sẽ xóa
đại này đi nên gi chưa Làm ăn được cái
gì
thằng admin cho nó đơn giản đi để để nó
admin 1 cũng được mà có sao đâu chỉ đổi
mỗi đây ở chỗ khác chạy được
mà
đó Ờ not f à Đợi tí c cách
đã đó xong
Ờ mình sẽ tạo sản phẩm mới đúng không
ạ sản phẩm này Thực ra là tạo sản phẩm
này nhưng mà nó không có ảnh thực ra là
gọi nhỉ hơi giác một tí nên là tôi cá
nhân tôi thì tôi nghĩ là có khi là cái
produc
chắc là không cần tôi nghĩ thế cái này
này tạm comment lại không cần
Ờ mình sẽ tạo một product mới
thị vs code có liên quan đến người cũ
Nhưng đấy không phải là người yêu đúng
không ạ Đó là một con hệ quan hệ Hồi đấy
còn không có khái niệm mập mờ cơ Bây giờ
mới có cơ đấy nhưng mà đại khái thế Nó
là một quan hệ bị bị cho không phải fan
Zone Nhưng kiểu kiểu C Thế hồi rất lâu
rồi
đấy nhưng là nhấn mạnh lại vẫn không
phải là người yêu ạ được là người yêu
thì tôi đã không như thế nó rơi ở một
con hệ mình cảm thấy rất là ba chấm nên
thành ra mình mới kỳ
thị h Tại sao Đợi đợi tôi tí Tại sao có
khái niệm Có cái có cái này trên này
trong ké này file này là file đây mình
xem update đúng không
ạ yeah Thằng này không xịn
bằng pp stor rồi à đâu Tôi không chắc
lắm đâu xem nhá
Cũng cũng cũng được cũng được cũng ghê
xo cái cái này hiển thị trước cái
product
luôn đây p title p title tôi đâu ạ Đây
name router à name router Cái này là B
tram các
thứ cứ sai sai nào nhỉ
chứ có bảo là không còn ai đâu Macbook
đâu rồi ạ Tôi bị ngại trả lời mấy câu
này rồi buồn
quá ai đó Trả lời Hội tôi vậy
ạ sim á Ừ tôi sim mà tôi nói tôi không
sim mà mình ler thì mình chỉ được cái
sim thôi chứ
đ k hập deskop í B Cái này tôi điền ở
trang khác nó đ xất ở đây ok sẽ điền
ạ đ chuẩn làm mấy cái ô này bắt buộc
phải điền nó hợp lý hơn thay vì kiểu
mình ấ enter là bắt là nhận luôn như thế
thì sẽ require như
này đấy đấy enter
enter
đấy
đó đúng không
ạ Cho bắt buộc phải điền các thứ
code passbook điên này f passbook điên
này thumbnail à
th bắt buộc Điền này Ờ con gì nhỉ nội
dung content này bắt buộc Điền này còn
cái
inmate
inmate ĐT buộc Điền
này Ok cái này cho khi nhờ sửa xong Ok
được đồng quảng cáo nào nhưng
mà thấy trên này hình ảnh sẽ copy các
thứ
thứ xem cái áo
[âm nhạc]
ok như là phần mô tả Hồi trước copy được
Bây giờ nó biến thành hình hình ảnh hết
rồi cái thật đấy copy phần đánh giá Vậy
à đây đây ơ cái này gì Tưởng không copy
được xem
đánh giá th đấy là một cái rất là xịn
theo 100 cành giá 200 cành À đây có hiệu
ứng này mà mình phải tận dụng chứ Đúng
rồi ảnh
logo trong ngầu thế này
đọc được cái này V
gì À đây đp đ này
đến đoạn giữa giữa này đọc được có lấy
đoạn này không Ok Ok
ông trả lời hộ tôi đấy
à max không có sampi thì xài app nào
tương tự được không ạ Thế sampi có có
hôm trước là tôi thấy là có cả trên Ờ
trên Apple đấy chứ hôm trước tôi tải là
thấy có rồi nhưng mà tôi không khuyên
mấy ông dùng s nữa tôi dùng ở trên công
ty tôi dùng l dog nhưng mà nhưng mà có
thể là mấy ông dùng lagon này cũng được
mấy cái này không cần nhất thiết phải
dùng larel thì mới mới cài các bạn cái
này để mà các bạn chạy pp là được
à đc thì nó sẽ có docker các thứ
ấy đó trống xịn nhở xịn mà đúng không
Tôi tự đánh giá là hồi đấy làm xịn Ơ cái
đoạn
này hết hạn à đượca
nhờ
invalid
password rồi chắc không sao
add copy
sinh sa copy cái này
ờ một
đâu
cái
nhỉ Đợi tí Đợi
tí u xem
[âm nhạc]
nàoy đây ở dưới này à
ha Không có Ha Ni à đây
nhỉ xem có lỗi
nét co đi Anh không biết tất cả về cái
đống Tôi vừa
đọc không biết trả lời nha cười thôi cứ
cười
nhỉ Xong rồi
[âm nhạc]
rồi
à đây copy cái
h
rồi sau đó thì ở dưới này dùng cái này
ok
nhầm chẽ thử
thì thì phải ừ anh đang nghĩ đến trường
hợp đấy mà rõ ràng là trong này Đề cập
cái vụ liên quan domain rồi
nhỉ Nãy nó chưa hể nói vụ liên quan
domain ấy nó bảo là ché thêm cái này Ở
trên
add cho ap key replay no api
này của
giờ thì báo thành như này ạ Đỉnh
bây giờ nó biến thành kiểu Read Only
được nhỉ
đâu đó đợi t Đợi tí Đợi một tí
ạ đổ cái này ra đây
key gì đây
đúng không U được không bỏ Min đi
để C Lư nó về đã ừ
này mà
về ờ đợi đợi tì Tôi sẽ xóa xử cái thằng
này đi
đã
admin Ok tạm
à Có thằng
này
for
read cái gì cái vừa rồi nó for Read Only
cái gì
đây for Read
thấy có khi là chỉ cần
cần t kh chỉ
cần asset nó xong chứ
admin
ồ g edit Phết Xem đúng luôn
bao Cái lỗi khác như không quan trọng
thì sửa thế nào sử dụng ai để
trả tiền thì nó sẽ hết
b chang test nữa là
Ồ thế Tại sao vừa rồi mình mất công ấ
nhá
yeah
mất cổng thật sự
class này làm gì đây đúng chứ Cái
require nữa đâu rồi nhỉ một cái require
nó vứt vào trong
trong tex Arrow rồi
đấy Cái này Không nhận
à
à quay trong này đúng lỗi tôi lỗi
rồi đó ok
sẽ thấy là tôi khổ nhưng mà khi mà tôi
sửa được thì mấy ông sẽ thấy là kiểu Ừ
thì biết cách làm để sửa giống tôi Thế
coi như là tôi mình tôi khổ thôi mấy ông
sướng là được đúng
vừa rồi không hề đề cập đến cái trang
kia đ
x cái cái kiểu Quick install các th thứ
ấ cái Collection này á dùng select 2 cái
thư viện này thư viện
link nhể
sang à ảnh K đi
này ví dụ là color đi đó
phí col tiếp
đi Tôi nhớ hồi trước tôi làm cái vụ phải
gợi ý cái cái lưu này rồi mà
nhở Kệ vậy
sai à
add miễn phí nghĩa là cái này không thể
không phải miễn phí mà chính xác là
không thêm tiền ấy đấy c l đi mất thêm
10.000 cái này chưa cập nhật như cái này
thông cản ơ sii V si tại này sii tiếp
đi
XL 20
bảo require ở đâu đấy Nhưng mà thực ra
là chắc chắn là do mình lỡ để cái
require ở đâu
xong tôi đang nghĩ là tôi để require ở
đâu đấy Xong rồi không xếp được
nhưng mà nhưng mà kiểu gọi
nhở Cái require này không hiển thị ra ok
đỉnh thật đấy đỉnh thật
sẽ mình sẽ dùng jquery để mà ép buộc nó
submit dùng jquery để for submit form
for qua
require
là cái
à Thằng do thằng content này này Mật
Công thật đấy Thằng này này require này
có phải nó không nhận này Ok Không sao ạ
Không sao Không sao Z file require
remove
require
ạ
Tôi vừa nãy tôi a gọi như
[âm nhạc]
Ừ tôi có cái A
submit nên là vừa nãy prevent default
nên thành ra nó mất luôn cả a nên nó
nhảy sang trang này chứ không phải lỗi
đâu
Thì
anh cái cái đánh giá sản phẩm thì anh
chưa làm Thực ra cái đấy dễ thôi em lưu
lại một bảng bảng review ấy xong rồi em
lưu lại thông tin kiểu product ID các
thứ em lưu lại
nhanh hơn chvt 4 không Tôi từng Tôi dùng
ở công ty copilot xố mà nhưng mà tôi vẫn
dùng song song với chat gvt thì chat VT
tôi sẽ hỏi những cái khác còn copilot
thì để có
ô nếu dùng docker thông thường mình làm
xong dự án mình mới Build image đúng
không anh Thực ra tôi không chuyên
docker đâu tôi kiểu được kiểu cứ thế cài
mà dùng thôi nên tôi cũng không tìm hiểu
sâu lắm về docker Nói chung là tôi cá
nhân tôi hướng sâu về kiểu ngôn ngữ lập
trình này và bên database chứ tôi không
tìm hiểu về mảng hệ thống đố hay các thứ
lắm n là cũng không giỏi về deploy làm
mọi thứ
khác team Anh ở dep có dùng chung DB
không là như nào nhỉ Ý em là là anh em
kết nối cùng chung DB để mà xài chung
hay là như nào
đó lên sản phẩm rồi ạ
Đúng chưa ạ đúng nhỉ Ơ bị mất ảnh
rồi ô sai sai ở đây Tại sao mất ảnh nhở
qué
đấy chang cái này xem có đánh dấu sao để
mà chỉ hiển thị ra đúng thằng này này ô
Ôi rồi n đ xóa hết xư mấy thằng kia đi
đấy status này content rỗng luôn Chứng
tỏ là vừa rồi mình điền vào
nhỉ
thăm U lên rồi mà nhỉ
À tôi nghĩ tại sao tôi biết tại sao
rồi à p
artisan link storage à storage link
à
này Đấy ảnh cũ còn có
nhá 100k này 200k
này ảnh
này được chưa ạ uầy điền lại cái này ờ l
quá là nó có khách sẵn rồi r
cũ ý thôi bắt đầu nghi nghi
này có truyền ảnh thăm
này một cái đoạn thì nó dài m dài vãi
trưởng này có truyền size này có truyền
ha product inage
này tôi sẽ D Kate cái trang này
ra có content vận bất
option nghĩa là cái này là cái hiển thị
cũ rồi chứ không phải là mình không lưu
được xem
này đấy có ảnh mà có ảnh
này đúng rồi Xin chúc mừng đây là code
cũ
lỗi đường dẫn nó sẽ phải hiển thị ra ảnh
ở đây bị lỗi nghĩa là phải có ảnh nhưng
mà nó bị
lỗi
Ok tôi
sẽ tôi bây giờ tôi bị lười tôi không có
code lại đâu tôi sẽ đi tìm lại code cũ ở
trên nhành máy má để mà tôi sửa lại cứ
tạm đẩy mấy cái này lên đã đ không ạ lờ
quá
update Factory
update vendor
sao rồi Cái
này
ờ
hôm n hơi bị lời động não mấy không ạ
thông
cảm đến giờ này thì đúng là lời động não
thôi anh ơi anh đã bị dính vụ table ở
trong C Editor khi gửi mail bị mất table
chưa
hả c
Editor m
table chưa em ạ Mà tại sao lại gửi mail
nhỉ Anh chưa hiểu ý em
lắm
nghĩa là th table lưu ở trong lưu bằng C
lưu trong DB đúng
không xong rồi khi gửi mail thì không
gửi không không gửi được table đấy á ha
như nào
nhỉ Nó chung em phải xác định rõ ra việc
là em đã lưu được đúng cái table vào
trong DB chưa Đã thì mới gửi mail đúng
không mail Lấy thông tin từ DB ra mà
đúng không cho làm sao qua từ C
được theo anh V một web bán hàng có
hydro payment các thứ Đi phỏng vấn thì
ok
không nghe em tả qua thì anh cũng hiểu
được là Ừ em cũng hiểu qua
là làm được một tí rồi nhưng mà em vẫn
chưa mô tả cho anh chi tiết là nó gồm
những tính năng gì khác nữa Nên
là nếu mà chỉ đơn giản thế thì đúng là
nó ít vẫn ít nó gọi là chưa trọn vẹn
được các tính
năng bài toán nghiệp vụ ấy chứ chỉ đơn
giản là kiểu nó nó nếu thế nó chỉ ở
trong web cao hơn trong web tin tức một
tí thôi em phải làm thêm vài cái nghiệp
vụ xịn hơn một tí em phải tham khảo Hồi
trước anh có phân tích một vài cái dự án
đồ án hai ấ sẽ bài toán nghiệm vụ nó cao
hơn còn không thì không khác gì Đồ án
một anh hướng dẫn các bạn cả
á không Đừng có nên đừng bao giờ nên
dùng chung DB ở môi trường dep thì may
ra là kiểu dạng là ờ thì trên trên môi
trường dep thì hi nhiên kết nối chung
cái DB Nhưng mà thường là không ngại gọi
như nh Nói chung là tôi sang dự án mới
này tôi dịch dòi lắm đ là gần như là môi
trường l khá là nó giống steaking hơn n
nó khá nó khá là kiểu gần giống
production qu nó không phải dữ điệu
production thôi Nhưng mà nó nó phải là
một môi trường ổn định để mà tester nữ
cả anh em de có thể lên đấy để test chứ
không phải là môi trường tạp nham hồi
trước là Bọn tôi ở local Bọn tôi tạo SH
tạp nham lời visit nên thành ra là kiểu
kết nối thẳng lên dep DB dep kiểu dạng
bởi vì trên đây có dữ liệu ấy x cuối
cùng thành dữ liệu đp cũng tạp nham theo
và bây giờ ch chỉ nên thành ra là cái
môi trường dep của bọn tôi nó khá là tù
rất nhiều vấn đề nên thành ra tester
cũng không thể test trên đấy đôi khi đôi
khi phải có khái niệm là đẩy code lên
production r test ở trên production nghe
test trên production nó bị nó bị kiểu
sai đúng không Ngay nghe cái nghiệp vụ
thấy sai rồi ý đấy nh Nếu có thể thì
phải giữ cho môi trường đ nó rất là ổn
định để mà có thể test được mọi thứ trên
đấy làm việc mọi thứ trên đấy còn Nếu mà
chuẩn hơn nữa thì phải tách hẳn th một
môi trường là staking là môi trường có
dữ liệu của gần nhất với production để
mình có thể test trên đấy một phát nữa
bởi vì Ờ Đôi khi tính năng nó chạy được
nhưng mà tính năng mà nó liên quan đến
dữ liệu thuật các lại không chạy được
không biết được nên là sẽ phải có môi
trường steaking nữa đấy công ty Nói
chung là công ty tôi thì chưa Làm hẳn
một môi
là để duy trì được cái môi trường
staking đấy đ nha các bạn sẽ phải tự lên
một con server Gì đó database Gì đó thì
lưu mấy cái đống đấy chạy đống đấy đúng
không ạ Đấy à Nên là nói chung là cái
này phải tùy tùy theo công ty linh hoạt
tùy the tài chính mọi
trước Ui 3 năm trước lâu lắm
rồi Ừ đúng nó thường ít nhất phải ba môi
trường local này dep xong rồi
production uat Ông bảo chắc là nó tương
tự khái niệm staking của tôi như đại
khái là mình C linh hoạt thôi là sao phù
hợp các thứ với tù mục đích của công ty
nữa công ty muốn kiểu nhanh
gọn nhưng mà nhanh thì nó sẽ đi kèm với
rất nhiều cái
kiểu nó có thể ch ổn định và vân vân
đúng
không WordPress development nhu cầu
Tuyền cao không không biết trả lời câu
đấy nha Nhưng mà bây giờ nhu cầu về web
tôi thấy là nó vẫn rất nhiều Bây ai cũng
muốn có một cái web
riêng nhưng mà tôi khuyến khích các bạn
là nếu mà làm được lập trình nên làm lập
trình chứ tôi không đành ra cao kiểu
WordPress magento các thứ thứ tôi không
coi được đấy là lập trình mà nó chỉ là
thiết kế web cả kéo thả các th thứ
nó ngoài việc là cái đấy Không biết cái
không quan tâm cái làm được như nào và
mọi người gọi là tiện lợi như nào mà tôi
thấy là ngay Việc học cái đấy và làm cái
đấy gọi nhở Cái tư duy quan trọng cái tư
duy ấ của một người dùng cái đấy làm cái
đấy nó khác với một người Làm lập trình
viên bình thường n tôi L không đánh
thánh Cao việc đấy
à
nói mento làm dễ hơn nhưng mà Cái quan
trọng là tôi tôi tiếp xúc tôi tiếp xúc
nhá Tôi chưa trực tiếp làm magento nên
tôi không thể đánh giá được Kiểu kiểu
dạng là kỹ hơn được nhưng mà tôi tiếp
xúc với những ông thừng nằm magento rồi
thì gọi nh ngoài tư duy ra ấ ông ấy đúng
kiểu ông chỉ làm Mao thôi Ông ấy không
nhảy sang làm ngôn ngữ khác các thứ các
thứ không biết ông ở đây có thế không
tôi từng gặp mấy kiểu khá nhiều người
như thế nên thành ra tôi cảm thấy đấy
một kiểu gọi như nào nhỉ Mình mình chưa
trải nghiệm nên là mình không thể đánh
giá được nhưng mà mình nếu mà mình đánh
giá qua những người mà đã trải nghiệm ấy
thì là một trảnh Thì đấy là một cái gì
một cái gọi gì à
à cho ác cảm à không có thiện cả Kiểu
cái
tham của K nhớ tài khoản thì làm
chữ S của một phiên em để default là 120
phút em có zin Nhữ tài khoản thì nó
gian sống tận 1 năm á Thế em phải học
lại về sison thi sison nó chỉ là kiểu H
nhớ không lầm nó giống kiểu cách lưu lại
như cách nó ngắn lắm Còn nếu mà em thực
sự một nó lưu lâu thì rõ ràng là em phải
làm nó giống kiểu lưu kiểu Token ấy rồi
nó hết hạn xong bao lâu em lưu lại trong
databas rồi em có so sánh kiểm tra xem
là nó đã hết hạn chưa chứ không không
bảo không không ai có thể nói là sison
ha kểu sống được lâu như thế cả vì gần
như là cái cách lưu season lưu cách thì
nó là gần như là em cứ tắt tắt thiết bị
đi kiểu ngắt đi gần như là nó cũng sẽ
tắt nó sẽ expire luôn cái season đấy
về kcn không phải kcn làm dep C các
thứ X Thăng là x sá
cứ làm thôi không sao cả
sao đâu ừ V đang đị Nói gì quên mất
rồi lú thật
ông có gì mấy ông xem video này chắc để
buổi sao tôi tâm sự sau nhá
Ừ còn Hôm nay chắc là tôi không còn thời
gian để tâm sự mấy ông nữa nó nhiều Ừ
chắc là tôi chia sẻ ông cái tin vui thôi
đó là hôm qua tôi kiểu rất là mệt rồi
tôi về tôi ngủ được lại rất là lâu rất
là lâu rồi tôi mới có thể ngủ sâu như
thế kiểu ngủ trọn vẹ được hơn 8 tiếng
một tầm 8 tiếng đã sâu đối hối trước là
tôi toàn kiểu 3:00 ngủ xong rồi 8:00 dậy
trong tình trạng mệt mỏi Xong rồi mãi
ngày hôm qua rất là mệt nhưng vẫn cố
thức để mà nói chung là đến tầm 11:00
tôi đi ngủ thô ch 8:00 hôm n dậy công
như là dậy trước được đồng hồ thức 2
phút 2 3 phút gì đấy cũng hay và rất là
tỉnh đến giờ vẫn cảm thấy khá là tỉ
nhưng mà bây giờ cũng gọi là cả ngày hôm
nay cũng mệt rồi Hi vọng là hôm nay lại
tiếp tục được thế Đúng là bây giờ mình
tuổi Tôi nghĩ là ừ hôm n nhắc lại tuổi
cũng già
rồi già già già nghe già một điển hình
mà Bởi vì kiểu bây giờ tôi đi dậy hồi
trước là tôi đi dậy hồi đầu tôi đi dậy
là lúc đấy Tôi sinh năm 97 đúng không
Tôi Hồi đấy tôi đi dạy khóa đầu tiên của
tôi đã ngay khóa sau ấy là 9899 cho cảm
thấy là lúc đấy mình còn trẻ Uầy bây giờ
đi dậy kiểu cái em 52 mà đã mà các em 52
mà cách mình tận 7 tuổi đấy lúc đấy mình
cảm thấy ủi B mình già vãi
trưởng Anh Bình hôm nay còn bồi thêm câu
nữa đó là đã già còn
đây đại khái à Tôi nghĩ à
Ờ bây giờ làm mọi thứ n cảm nhận rõ được
luôn kiểu nó ảnh hưởng sức khỏe như nào
sợ thật nên bây giờ tôi sẽ phải nghỉ
ngơi và tập dục các thứ thử tôi nghĩa là
nó sẽ tốt hơn ví dụ bây giờ sẽ đi ngủ
sớm này sẽ tắt máy xong rồi một lúc nữa
ngủ luôn ạ hy vọng là mấy ông cũng nên
giữ sức ông thức đến giờ này Ngồi nghe
tôi chém gió chắc là buôn ngủ rồi ạ ngủ
thôi nhỉ À nhầ nghì ngơ thôi nhỉ Đấy ngi
sớm nhá Chào mấy ông nhá Hôm nào Ừ hôm
nào tôi có thể hướng đ tôi sẽ làm
Podcast kiểu tâm sự gì gì đó để tôi ngủ
mấy
ông Ok không hở gì nữa Chào mấy ông nhé
Bye